I said a couple trailers so we got a
couple trailers the next trailer we're
going to talk about is the trailer to
Transformers Dark of the Moon so as all
of you know transformers 2 I really hate
it so I am eternally skeptical of
Transformers Dark of the Moon that being
said it looks really cool so in this
trailer we find out that our entire
space race of the 1960's was in response
to an event which I find really weird
cuz wouldn't you think the sector 7 guys
in the first one they would know about
that like oh yeah we got this robot
frozen in the basement because of you
know that whole thing in any case
transforming is pretty pointless now
because the Decepticons are just rolling
in they're invading it's an invasion
movie hopefully it can be what battle
Los Angeles really wasn't for me after
that a lot of robots a lot of explosions
a lot of cool-looking [ __ ] and this beat
a hundred times over time which is funny
because why are they taking over our
planet I mean the first one they were
looking for the cube the second one they
were trying to make a movie I remember
they're just bar they're like we've been
hiding under the moon for so long we
just need to kill [ __ ] I flush your
little sacs called humans let's do it
and when anyone in the movie says things
like this everything humans know of our
planet we were told had been shared
you lied to us
a grave mistake it just sounds to me
like they're making a way to write stuff
in but hey came from prime Robo Jesus so
we don't argue I mean you can't say the
movie looks boring from this trailer it
has a lot of cool summer movie looking
stuff so yeah I want to say it it looks
like it's all coming down to this but
why is John Turturro back he annoyed me
in the last two movies he was just that
comic relief guy that know and Shia
LaBeouf needs to find something else to
yell it's almost like he's done that
before so judging by the trailer it
looks like they're cutting back on all
that really cheesy humor stuff and
they're concentrating on the invasion
and it looks hardcore invasion to these
transformers are just rolling in and
yeah they're taking us out and the
trailer ends on a final note from Robo
Jesus you may lose your faith in us but
never in your selves thanks prime and
then the hentai tentacles come out of
nowhere and squeeze that building and
knock it over there is that so if this
movie sticks to what it should be which
is a really cool Transformers movie a
good action movie a good action alien
invasion movie life should be good as
long as I leave out the racist robots
cut back on the stupid parents and cut
back on the humor good have ourselves a
sweet-ass movie there's a transformer
dragon is awesome so I put a link to the
trailer below go check it out come back
here comment below let me know what you
think but if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you